sources are one of the important ways
chefs add extra dimension and flavor to
dishes you can use this trick at home my
camera's cranberry applesauce is another
recipe I always cook a day in advance it
packs a wonderful punch that really
lifts the subtle flavor of the turkey
it's simple to make and with its deep
red vibrant color looks fantastic on the
plate the secret behind any good
Christmas is in the organization and
preparation anything you can get done in
advance do it apple and cranberry sauce
is a prime example first things first
we're gonna make a really nice caramel
sugar in at 150 grams of caster sugar to
a pan followed by a couple of star anis
there helps to really give a nice sort
of aniseed flavor to the cranberries
next lightly crushed four cardamom pods
this has a lovely warm spicy sweet
flavor then wait for the sugar to melt
and form a caramel brilliant point out
the confers now to color that caramel so
gets really nice and dark before put the
cranberries
[Music]
Wow smell of that camera is amazing
now cranberries in families are very
tart and acidic but balanced with the
sweetness of the caramel and apples they
give the sauce a lovely dry sharp note
to tell if they're fresh drop them on a
hard service the higher they bounce the
fresher they are the secret now is sort
of caramel to blister the cranberries
and really start to break that down
smells fantastic next core peel and
thinly sliced 2 apples what's the sauce
is finished it really just helps to sort
of wake up the flavor of the turkey now
the creme breeze our standard rake down
Apple Inn smells fantastic a touch of
salt pepper that's really important
really helps to balance that tartness
against the acidity of the Apple song
pepper really brings it back the smell
is fantastic so I sort of sweet sour
spicy nice now from there
deglaze the pan with touch a port around
the side the glazing dissolves all the
lovely sticky cam ice bits of food that
are stuck to the pan
and incorporates them into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange and for
another layer of fragrant sweetness
squeezing the juice then cook on a low
heat for five to ten minutes to thicken
but remember the sort will become even
thicker once it's cooled down now that
is the right texture I don't want a
runny sauce I want something really nice
and thick delicious packed full of
flavor
perfect if you really want to get ahead
this sauce can be made three or four
days in advance and kept in the fridge
which allows the flavors to develop even
more
[Music]
then on Christmas Day simply bring it up
to room temperature and serve another
job done leaving you more time to enjoy
this very special day
[Music]